- [Scott] I, personally,
always had a bit of an affinity
towards finding things that're unexpected.
So, I find it incredible that,
here in Dubai,
we do have this world-class
surfing community,
and we do have waves.
Dubai's typically known
for the high-rises,
and five-star luxury.
I think this kind of bohemian,
underground surf-culture,
mixing with that,
is just a pretty beautiful thing.
(tinkling ambient music)
My name is Scott Chambers,
and I'm the founder and
CEO of Surf House Dubai.
I was born in Sharjah in the UAE.
The UAE was a very different
place back then, in the ‘90s,
and yeah, surfing culture
was really non-existent
at the time.
Over the last 25 years,
the surf community's grown tremendously.
Dubai actually sits in the ideal location
to pick up the best swells
that come through the Arabian Gulf.
It just makes it a very favorable place
to learn how to surf.
My friendship with Fahim
started 20 years back,
when we were in high school together.
We shared a love for
the water and for surfing.
- Scott and a group of his
friends were the first surfers
in Dubai,
a long time ago,
uh, and I saw them out in the water,
and I wanted to do what they were doing.
And I remember paddling out for my first time,
and catching that first wave,
and I was totally hooked.
As Scott grew the surfing community,
there was an opportunity for me
to come on board as a
partner in the business,
and us to create this new embassy,
for the surfing community.
Dubai in the United
Arab Emirates is a place
that supports small businesses to grow,
and for people to really create
really innovative concepts.
The exhilaration and the
connection with the ocean
is something that just can't be described.
It promotes that ocean culture,
that ocean-minded, uh, consciousness,
of, of our environment.
Surfing transcends
cultures, nationalities.
It's so amazing to see, you know,
Emiratis and non-Emiratis
both get out in the water,
and have an absolutely great time,
sharing the same experience.
- [Scott] At the end of the day,
we're trying to share
this love for the sport,
and we do teach Emiratis,
as well as eastern and
western expatriates,
and once you're in there,
you never wanna get out.